turquía acaba de confirmar hace unas
pocas horas que se desentiende
completamente del caso del asesinato del
periodista saudí yamaha sería asesinado
en el consulado de su país en estambul
en octubre de 2018 hace algo menos de
cuatro años así lo ha confirmado el
ministerio de justicia turco esta misma
mañana cuando ha afirmado que traspasar
a la totalidad de este caso desde
turquía arabia saudí para que continúa
allí y los 26 presuntos asesinos de de
schamann jasso y que vinieron
expresamente para aprender y asesinar al
periodista desde árabe saudí a estambul
continuarán siendo juzgados en arabia
saudí una decisión muy criticada tanto
por organizaciones de derechos humanos
como por naciones unidas que explican
que este proceso judicial no tendrá las
garantías necesarias
ni tendrá un desenlace justo en arabia
saudí cuyo gobierno según explican
muchos informes de inteligencia fue el
que precisamente ordenó el asesinato de
llamadas y una decisión esta de turquía
de mandar el caso judicial desde turquía
a árabe soy muy criticada también por la
prometida de esa marca seguí
en la ciudadana turca hatice aseguró
cuando se anunció la decisión de turquía
de pasar este caso judicial catalogó
esta decisión de una desgracia y aseguró
hacer todo lo posible para evitarlo hoy
ha confirmado a jenkins que apelará esta
decisión e intentará que el proceso
judicial que será pasado arabia saudi
continúa en turquía